THIS EVENING.
THAT'S WHEN WE EXPECT ROUND 14
OF THE VOTE FOR SPEAKER.
EARLIER TODAY MEMBERS GATHERED
OUTSIDE THE CAPITOL TO MARK TWO
YEARS SINCE THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION.
ONLY ONE REPUBLICAN SHOWED UP
THERE, CONGRESSMAN BRIAN
FITZPATRICK OF JOINS ME.
PROSECUTORS ARE STILL TRYING TO
BRING RIOTERS TO JUSTICE.
SOME COULD STILL FACE ARRESTS
STEMMING FROM THE ATTACK.
>> Reporter: YEAH, THE FBI SAYS
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP AT THIS.
ONE OF THEIR BIG FOCUSES ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO ASSAULTED POLICE
OFFICERS.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE NUMBERS
AFTER TWO YEARS OF THIS EFFORT
BY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
OVER 950 PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED.
WE KNOW OF 280 WHO HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH ASSAULT, RESISTING
OR IMPEDING SOME OF THE OFFICERS
THERE AT THE SCENE.
484 GUILTY PLEAS SO FAR.
THERE'S STILL ABOUT 40
DEFENDANTS WHO HAVE BEEN FOUND
GUILTY IN TRIALS, INCLUDING ONE
TODAY, WE SAW TODAY ONE OF THE
FIRST RIOTERS WHO KICKED DOWN A
DOOR AND WAS ONE OF THE FIRST TO
GET INTO THE CAPITOL, HE WAS
SENTENCE TO DO 48 MONTHS IN
PRISON AS A RESULT OF THAT.
>> AND, EVAN, CONSPIRACY CHARGES
ARE ONE OF THE MOST SERIOUS AT
THE HEART OF THE TRIAL AGAINST
THE MEMBERS OF THE PROUD BOYS.
WHERE DOES THAT CASE STAND AT?
>> IT'S IN JURY SELECTION RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S BEEN INTERESTING, OUR TEAM
THERE DESCRIBED A VERY
CONTENTIOUS EFFORT TO SEAT A
JURY.
WE EXPECT OPENING ARGUMENTS TO
HAPPEN NEXT WEEK.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY'VE
STRUGGLED WITH IS, OBVIOUSLY,
THE REPUTATION OF THE PROUD BOYS
IN THE CITY, GETTING PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE STRONG VIEWS ABOUT
THEM HAS BEEN A BIT OF A
CHALLENGE FOR PROSECUTORS AND
FOR THE DEFENSE.
WE EXPECT, OBVIOUSLY, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY CHARGES AGAINST OATH
KEEPERS, SO THEY FEEL PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT THIS TRIAL.
>> EVAN PEREZ, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>>> LET'S BRING IN MICHAEL
FANONE, A CNN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ANALYST AND POLICE OFFICER WHO
ALMOST DIED AT THE HANDS OF THAT
PRO-TRUMP MOB AS HE TRIED TO
DEFEND THE CAPITOL DURING THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION TWO
YEARS AGO.
HE'S ALSO THE AUTHOR OF "HOLD
THE LINE: THE INSURRECTION AND
ONE COP'S BATTLE FOR AMERICA'S
SOUL" AND HE IS FRESH OFF A
VISIT TO THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE
HE WAS ONE OF 14 PEOPLE TO
RECEIVE ONE OF THE HIGHEST
HONORS GIVEN TO CIVILIANS, THE
PRESIDENTIAL CITIZENS MEDAL.
FIRST OF ALL, CONGRATULATIONS ON
THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
YOUR GIRLS ARE HERE.
WERE THEY IN THE AUDIENCE?
>> THEY WERE.
>> DID THEY GET TO SEE?
>> THEY DID.
THEY GOT TO MEET THE PRESIDENT.
FANTASTIC.
>> AND PEOPLE MIGHT NOT KNOW
THIS, BUT YOU VOTED FOR TRUMP.
HERE YOU ARE WITH JOE BIDEN.
WAS THAT WEIRD, OR HAS THIS ALL
BEEN PART OF THIS LONG STRANGE
TRIP YOU'VE BEEN ON?
>> IT'S PART OF THE LONG STRANGE
TRIP YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT.
I VOTED FOR TRUMP IN 2016, I
VOTED FOR BIDEN IN 2020.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I WAS GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED, NOT SO MUCH FOR
WHAT I DID ON JANUARY 6th, BUT
FOR EVERYTHING THAT I'VE DONE
AND WHAT SO MANY OTHER AMERICANS
THAT WERE RECOGNIZED TODAY HAVE
DONE SINCE THEN.
>> YOU AND YOUR FELLOW OFFICERS
WERE BEATEN, YOU HAD A HEART
ATTACK.
IT WAS A HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE.
THERE'S BEEN PHYSICAL RECOVERY
AND EMOTIONAL RECOVERY, I'M
SURE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING ON THIS
TWO-YEAR ANNIVERSARY?
>> I MEAN, WITH REGARDS TO THE
INJURIES I SUSTAINED THAT DAY ON
JANUARY 6th, I FEEL I'VE MADE A
FULL RECOVERY.
>> THE PHYSICAL ONES?
>> THE PHYSICAL ONES AND, YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, I HAD A 20-YEAR
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT, TO
KIND OF DESENSITIZE ME TO THE
VIOLENCE I EXPERIENCED THAT DAY.
SO I BELIEVE THAT I'VE, YOU
KNOW, COME TO TERMS WITH THE
TRAUMA OF JANUARY 6th, THE DAY.
WHAT CONTINUES -- OR WHAT I
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH IS
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED SINCE
THEN AND THE THINGS, THE ISSUES
THAT WE CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH
AS A COUNTRY REGARDING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, THE LIES THAT
HE SPEWED AND THE POLITICAL
VIOLENCE THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
AS A RESULT OF IT.
>> AND ON THAT SUBJECT, WHILE
YOU WERE THERE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE BEING HONORED WITH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS AND
INDEPENDENTS BY THE PRESIDENT
FOR STANDING UP FOR DEMOCRACY,
YOU FOR LITERALLY PROTECTING
DEMOCRACY WITH YOUR LIFE, ON THE
OTHER SIDE, OTHER END OF
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, REPUBLICANS
ARE WORKING TO ELECT A SPEAKER.
THAT SPEAKER IS GOING TO BE
MAYBE KEVIN McCARTHY, WHO YOU
WROTE IN AN OPINION ARTICLE ON
CNN.COM, McCARTHY TOLD YOU THAT
HE COULDN'T CONTROL THE FRINGE
MEMBERS OF THE PARTY AND SOME
PEOPLE SEE WHAT HE'S DOING RIGHT
NOW, NOT CERTAINLY WITH ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN AGAINST
HIM, BUT WITH SOME OF THEM, AS
EMPOWERING THEM.
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY, FOR
EXAMPLE, HE'S NECK DEEP IN
JANUARY 6th, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ASKED FOR HIS PHONE
RECORDS, INTRODUCING JEFF CLARK
TO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO
TRY TO GET HIM TO BE THE HEAD OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, ET
CETERA.
I COULD GO ON.
IS IT WEIRD TO BE HONORED FOR
YOUR ROLE IN SAVING DEMOCRACY
WHILE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO
SEEM TO BE OPPONENTS OF THAT
DEMOCRACY ARE HAVING A HELL OF A
TIME IN CONGRESS RIGHT NOW?
A GOOD TIME, I MEAN.
>> I MEAN, LISTEN, NOBODY ENJOYS
WATCHING KEVIN McCARTHY SQUIRM
MORE THAN ME.
I'M NOT A FAN.
I DON'T THINK HE POSSESSES ANY
LEADERSHIP QUALITY, LET ALONE
THE QUALITY TO LEAD THE HOUSE.
THAT BEING SAID, I RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT WHILE HE STRUGGLES,
IT'S EMPOWERING THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, LIKE YOU JUST
DESCRIBED, EITHER THESE
INSURRECTIONIST SYMPATHIZING
MEMBERS OR, YOU KNOW, MEMBERS
WHO MAY HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
INSURRECTION AT THE CAPITOL
THEMSELVES.
AND SO THAT'S DEEPLY CONCERNING.
BECAUSE THEY REPRESENT SUCH A
SMALL SEGMENT OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
SYMPATHETIC TO JANUARY 6th
REPRESENT SUCH A SMALL PART OF
OUR COUNTRY.
BUT YET HERE THEY ARE BEING
EMPOWERED AND EMBOLDENED BY A
WEAK, FECKLESS CANDIDATE FOR
SPEAKER.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT CONDEMNING
POLITICAL VIOLENCE, NOT BEING A
DEMOCRATIC ISSUE OR REPUBLICAN
ISSUE.
I COMPLETELY AGREE.
YOU SAY IT'S A MORAL ISSUE.
BUT IT'S WEIRD, BECAUSE THERE
WAS A HOUSE CEREMONY MARKING THE
TWO-YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THAT
HORRIFIC ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL,
IN WHICH EVERYBODY'S LIFE WAS AT
STAKE.
THEY WERE TRYING TO HANG MIKE
PENCE, WE SAW IMAGES OF MITT
ROMNEY BEING ESCORTED AWAY BY
POLICE, I THINK BY EUGENE
GOODMAN, I'M NOT SURE.
DEMOCRATS LIVES WERE AT STAKE,
REPUBLICANS LIVES WERE AT STAKE,
AND YET ONLY ONE REPUBLICAN
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WENT TO THAT
EVENT TODAY, CONGRESSMAN BRIAN
FITZPATRICK, REPUBLICAN FROM
OUTSIDE PHILLY, GREAT
COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> I'LL SAY THIS, OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
OUTSPOKEN OR YEAR THAT I'VE BEEN
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT JANUARY 6th, I
HAVE TRIED TO WALK A FINE LINE
WHEN IT COMES TO CONDEMNING
REPUBLICANS.
NOBODY LIKES TO BE PAINTED WITH
A BROAD BRUSH, LAW ENFORCEMENT
CERTAINLY DOESN'T LIKE THAT.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT ALL
REPUBLICANS ARE SYMPATHETIC TO
THE MAGA AGENDA.
THAT BEING SAID, IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO DEFEND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHEN ONLY ONE
OF THEIR MEMBERS TAKES THE TIME
TO SHOW UP AND SHOW SUPPORT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT WAS THERE
DEFENDING THEM THAT DAY.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT FOR THEIR
PARTY AND IT'S DISGRACEFUL
BEHAVIOR.
AND AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS
PREVIOUSLY SUPPORTED REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES, IT'S SHAMEFUL.
BUT THEY SEEM TO BE A PARTY AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THAT IS
WITHOUT SHAME.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MR. FANONE, GOOD TO SEE